bonjour à tous donc nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir pour notre point
presse patrick ollier qui est député
maire de rueil malmaison et qui est
délégué général en charge des relations
avec les groupes parlementaires qui va
nous faire un petit point sur la
mobilisation des maires qui est très qui
a été très importante samedi
auparavant je vous propose notre point
un jeune d'à de la semaine avec mardi à
15 heures un entretien de nicolas
sarkozy avec françois asselin qui est
président de la cgpme
mardi toujours à 18 heures le bureau
politique au siège des républicains
mercredi 23 septembre nicolas sarkozy se
rendra au sommet du parti populaire
européen à bruxelles et à 18 heures il
viendra faire un discours lors d'une
réunion militante qui aura lieu à
l'occasion des journées parlementaires à
reims
jeudi 24 septembre à 15 heures clôture
des journées parlementaires avec le
discours de nicolas sarkozy pour cette
clôture et vendredi 25 septembre
nicolas sarkozy se rendra à barcelone l
invitation de mariano rajoy à l'occasion
d'un meeting pour soutenir le parti
popular puisque vous savez que en
espagne auront lieu les élections
régionales donc quelques semaines avant
les élections régionales en france
et puis dimanche 27 septembre et bien
partir de 10 heures
nicolas sarkozy sera présent à la
réunion publique de valérie pécresse qui
est tête de liste des républicains donc
en ile-de-france et réunion qui aura
lieu à nogent sur marne
voilà je veux pas tout de suite la
parole à patrick ollier
concernant cette mobilisation très
importante des mères à l'initié à
l'initiative
de la ms merci bonjour à toutes et à
tous l'association des maires de france
après initiative extrêmement importante
extrêmement courageuse parce qu'elle a
lancée mais gauche et droite confondues
dans le cadre du bureau de l'association
des maires de france
une manifestation dans toutes les
mairies samedi qui a été parfaitement
respectée c'est une manifestation de
protestation car les maires quelle que
soit leur couleur politique sont
confrontés à un problème quasiment à ce
lip ce plan financier je m'explique
rapidement le gouvernement d'une manière
totalement irresponsable avec une
brutalité exceptionnelle a fait voter
une loi dans le projet de loi
rectificative en 2013 juin qui
brutalement coupe 11 milliards d'euros
de dotation donner aux collectivités et
à partir de là sans aucune concertation
c'est bien ce que la mère et tous les
maires de france reproche car nous
sommes tout à fait d'accord pour
envisager et réaliser des économies
faut-il qu'ils aient une concertation de
gouvernement et l'association
et faut-il que ensemble nous décidions
de ce qu'il faut faire c'est parce qu'il
s'est passé le résultat c'est que les
villes avec 30% de retrait pour les
communes de dotations sur 2015 2016 2017
se trouve confronté à l'effet ciseau qui
est quasiment impossible à résoudre dans
toutes les villes de france
je répète qu'on soit de gauche ou de
droite parce que ce retrait de dotation
qui s'ajoutent aux dépenses
supplémentaires que nous a imposé
j'en cite qu'une si les rythmes
scolaires par exemple la ville que je
dirige à rueil malmaison c'est un
million cinq cent mille euros par an +
ce n'est quand même pas rien et d'autres
encore qu on pourrait citer cet effet de
cumulation entre les dotations qu'on
nous retire sans concertation et des
pansements les impose font que les
maires sont obligés d'abord d'augmenter
les tarifs pour la population voire même
de supprimer des services à la
population et enfin de ne plus investir
parce que la capacité d'investissement
des communes est tout à fait opérer en
2013 c'était 35 milliards d'euros que
les communes investissent
et en 2015 ces 22 milliards d'euros je
passe y voyez la chute chez 72% à peu
près les collectivités territoriales
d'investissement public et pour les
communes c'est de l'ordre de 25%
c'est à dire que je reprends l'exemple
de ma vie mais je suis pas le seul cette
année ses investissements 0 ce qui veut
dire quand on regarde l'augmentation
pour les populations ou des impôts et
des tarifs et que regarde la diminution
voire la suppression des investissements
c'est un nouvel effet ciseaux parce que
pour les investissements sur des
entreprises qui ferment leurs portes
parce que non plus de chantier et pour
l'amélioration de la qualité de la vie
des citoyens c'est un handicap majeur
voilà donc si on rajoute à tout cela les
normes auxquelles nous sommes soumis et
le refus du gouvernement de desserrer
les contraintes de ces normes pour nous
donner un peu de souplesse dans la
gestion vous avez là un ensemble qui est
explosif et c'est pour ça que les maires
de france se sont mobilisés moi je
remercie le président sarkozy qui a
anticipé tout ça puisqu'il a créé un
comité des mères d'un autre mouvement
les républicains y l'a confié à hubert
falco genre terre ça n'occupe très
activement
moi même j'ai avec quelques amis
philippe brillault dans les yvelines aux
chaînés pemex dans les hauts-de-seine et
quelques heures nous avons créé le
comité des mères en colère ont lancé une
dynamique s'était mois de juin dernier
une dynamique qui aboutit aujourd'hui
effectivement ce que l'ensemble de la
nation se rendre compte de la situation
dont nous ne sommes pas responsables et
que pourtant nous assumons et le fait
est que le gouvernement dans une parce
qu'il fait n'assume pas ses
responsabilités d'économies budgétaires
et oblige de mer à le faire à sa place
je schématise un peu mais c'est
malheureusement la réalité
voilà pourquoi je vous remercie de leur
permis d'intervenir je voulais répondre
aux questions ciena merci patrick healy
a eu également pendant le week-end de ce
dimanche donc
des élections partielles et nous
adressons toutes nos félicitations et
nous réjouissons de la belle élection de
brigitte martini qui est désormais
désormais pardon maire républicain de
noisy le grand et donc on a vu à
l'occasion d'ailleurs de cette élection
que le fn ps sur noisy le grand et est
une réalité puisque entre les deux tours
de cette élection municipale
le front national a fait distribuer un
tract appelant à faire battre la
candidate des républicains d'une
heureusement cela a été déjoué par les
électeurs qui ont décidé de choisir donc
brigitte marcigny comme nouvelle maire
de noisy le grand
est ce qui fait d'ailleurs que les
républicains sont la première force
politique en seine saint denis
désormais ce qui est un beau symbole
dans la perspective des élections
régionales du mois de décembre
et puis autre motif de satisfaction
c'est la réélection dès le premier tour
de chantal brunel a busy bussy pardon
saint georges
on voit bien que le parti socialiste
s'effondre dans le département de claude
bartolone est certain c'est un très très
bon signal pour pour les régionales
voilà la stratégie des républicains
porte ses fruits et nous allons la
poursuivre puisque chaque élection est
l'occasion de voir que le front national
s'effondre et que le parti socialiste
également père voilà donc maintenant
nous allons passer à la consultation
/ / / l'immigration donc c'est un grand
succès de la démocratie directe qui a
voulu nicolas sarkozy au sein de notre
famille politique puisque 53 mille
militants ont participé en 48 heures à
ce vote
cent mille ont été ont été sollicités
par email ou un ou par sms donc c'est un
c'est un grand succès c'est la
démocratie directe qui s'installe dans
notre famille politique démocratie
directe qui était voulu par les
militants mais également par les grandes
voix de notre de notre famille c'est un
résultat qui est assez clair et sans
appel
nos militants ont clairement fait le
choix de ne pas tomber dans le déni de
réalité et de l'assimilation plutôt que
de l'intégration puisque rappelons le
l'intégration raté s'appelle le
communautarisme et l'intégration réussie
s'appelle tout simplement l'assimilation
donc cette consultation va servir de
base à la réflexion et aux projets des
républicains sera l'un des premiers
blocs de notre socle commun les
militants seront régulièrement
sollicités pour pour apporter leur
contribution à ce projet de nombreux
parlementaires ont été sollicités pour
cette journée de travail mais également
en amont puisque dès le 1er juillet il y
avait eu une journée de travail pour
préparer celle de mercredi mardi soir
également il ya eu une réunion pour
préparer 7,7 cette journée qui était
ouverte aux journalistes
donc demain il y aura une présentation
des résultats au bureau politique par
par eric woerth puis appuyez un débat
est évidemment comme je vous le disais
cela fera partie du socle commun du
projet d des républicains alors on a
l'impression que monsieur cambadélis a
été inspiré par par notre part notre
volonté de mettre plus de démocratie
directe dans le fonctionnement de notre
famille politique et a eu l'idée un
petit peu saugrenue
mais qui démontre finalement qu'il est
dans une détresse totale puisque le
parti socialiste un peu comme un
naufragé qui qui voit les rochers qui
sent qu'il va qui va se fracasser contre
ces rochers à la proche des régionales
il est il a demandé à ce qu'il y ait un
référendum pour pour que l'ensemble des
partis de gauche aillent rassemblés dès
le premier tour bon il a il a échoué à
les convaincre de se rassembler
c'est cet échec est dû au fait qu'il n'y
a plus aucune ligne idéologique au sein
du parti socialiste et qu'ils sont
totalement divisée éclaté mais ce n'est
qu'une vaine manoeuvre pour pouvoir
sauver quelques postes pouvoir sauver
quelques sièges al'approche des
régionales donc je vois la retrouve
senna c'est une attitude un peu de
suiveurs de la part de monsieur
cambadélis en plus c'est fait dans une
dans une méthode pour qu'on a du mal à
comprendre puisque personne n'a été
sollicitée monsieur valls et hollande
on dit qu'il n'avait pas du tout été
sollicités c'est le cafouillage mais
voilà c'est le sos d'un terrien en
détresse à la proche al'approche des
régionales on va maintenant passer à
monsieur macro sébastien mais on voit
que le ps est à la dérive et le ps veut
absolument faire l'union derrière lui
derrière lui le problème c'est que
personne de faire l'union avec le parti
socialiste ni les verts ni le parti
gauche ni les communistes et donc
monsieur cambadélis a trouvé donc ce
succédané de démocratie directe
une manière un peu ridicule d'ailleurs
pour essayer de convaincre tout le monde
de venir avec lui
et d'ailleurs nous attendons avec
beaucoup d'impatience de voir monsieur
combat délice sur les marchés avec sa
creissels et puis son urne pour essayer
de sauver
finalement le paquebot parti socialiste
qui est en détresse comme vient de le
dire
lydia et puis on a eu encore un ministre
à la dérive puisque nous avons eu
également une nouvelle macro nerie cette
semaine où monsieur macron après avoir
fustigé les 35 heures ont mis en cause
l'assurance chômage
remisé en cause le contrat de travail
est bien a décidé finalement une
nouvelle fois de s'attaquer à un totem
de la gauche le statut de la fonction
publique
donc nous attendons la macro nerie
suivante d'ailleurs qui pourrait
concerner lisf puisque monsieur mac ont
finalement a décidé de braconner sur les
terres des républicains et de revenir et
de venir prendre finalement dans nos
idées dans nos valeurs des choses qu'ils
trouvent plutôt positif pour notre pays
donc finalement soit monsieur macron
crois vraiment ce qui dit et finalement
il devrait se poser la question de
prendre sa carte chez les républicains
soit c'est une stratégie avec concerter
avec monsieur valls et monsieur hollande
pour essayer d'élargir le spectre de ses
électeurs vous avez que le parti
socialiste était en manque des lecteurs
on le voit élection après élection est
donc dans ce cas là on est en train de
de gruger les français en essayant bien
par petites touches d'essayer d'aller
chercher dans tous les électorats alors
chacun sait
c'est réparti le travail certains vont
chercher plus à gauche
d'autres plus à droite mais les
électeurs ne s'y trompa devant ce
capharnaüm finalement que qu'est devenu
ce gouvernement où on ne sait plus qui
tient la barre est ce qu'il ya une
direction vraiment on louvoie en
permanence et donc ce serait bien qu'il
y ait enfin à la fin de ce quinquennat
un peu de cohérence dans ce gouvernement
et dans les déclarations qui sont faites
voilà comme le disait sébastien au final
on est un peu dans une stratégie
d'enfumage de la part du gouvernement à
travers les prises de position de deux
ministres macro c'est c'est
l'incohérence de ce gouvernement un coup
on est social libéral un coup on est
plutôt tendance communiste
on n'y comprend rien les français n'y
comprennent plus rien et les français se
détournent simplement des des
socialistes et de la gauche qui mène le
pays vers la dégradation de sa note donc
l' agence moody's comme les deux autres
agences ont dégradé gradés la note de la
france on passe à aa2 les raisons
avancées c'est que la croissance
lacroix nous n'avons pas de perspectives
de croissance la croissance est atone et
il y à des politiques qui sont
incompréhensibles et des contraintes
légales et politiques qui pèsent sur les
entreprises qui sont de plus en plus
lourdes
donc la dérive économique de la france
poursuit et nous atteignons à le
souligner car cela est encore une fois
un très mauvais signal pour les marchés
est un très mauvais signal pour les
français oui nous nous apercevons que
malgré ce que nous disent à longueur de
temps
manuel valls et françois hollande
comme quoi tous les clignotants seraient
ouverts que la croissance revient que
tout va bien dans le meilleur des mondes
et que finalement le chômage n'est qu'un
épiphénomène
eh bien on s'aperçoit que des experts
indépendants que sont les experts de
chez moody's et bien eux sont inquiets
pour notre pays en disant qu' il y à un
manque de croissance en france notamment
lorsqu'on regarde par rapport aux pays
de l'union européenne qui nous entourent
qui eux ont tous retrouvé les chemins de
la croissance qui ont un chômage qui
baisse
eh bien la france est dans un phénomène
inverse du finalement à la politique à
la gribouille qui est menée par le
gouvernement le blocage des
investissements des collectivités
territoriales et j'ai rappelé les
chiffres tout à l'heure va contribuer à
aggraver situation que tu dis parce que
c'est quand même sur 72 % des
investissements publics communes
cévennes 5% et que va se produire ce
tassement qui va avoir des conséquences
qui ne sont pas encore comprise dans des
calculs et des bilans mais quand ça va
tomber dans quelques mois on s'aperçoit
que la situation ne fait que s'aggraver
je signale au passage c'est quand même
scandaleux pour les collectivités
territoriales ou représentant les
mairies 9 5% de la dette publique
on va très bien qui est dans la tête je
vois une affiche derrière ted hollande
épuise la france c'est bien c'est très
clair 9 5% et on nous demande à nous les
maires de faire 25 % d'efforts 25% des
femmes qui pèse sur nos épaules 9%
je ne sais pas mais fait logique
la latitude est donc cette politique en
zigzag que j'évoquais se manifeste
également dans l' annonce qui a été
faite par le gouvernement d'un décalage
de trois mois sur les exonérations de
charges liées au séisme
le sentiment que ça donne c'est que
personne au gouvernement ne sait comment
fonctionne une entreprise puisque on
annonce ici au mois de septembre que en
janvier à partir de janvier les
exonérations de charges qui devait être
accordée allait être reportée trois mois
un budget dans une entreprise ne se fait
pas du jour au lendemain ça se fait avec
beaucoup d'avancé sur les
investissements sur les dépenses a
exercé et donc le fait pour le
gouvernement de vouloir économiser un
milliard d'euros sur le dos des
entreprises malgré les annonces malgré
les engagements malgré les promesses
et bien c'est un un coup dur qui est
portée vis-à-vis de nos entreprises
alors faudra pas que le gouvernement
s'étonne quand suit la courbe du chômage
continue à augmenter et qu'il est si
difficile de l'inverser malgré tout les
engagements qui ont été pris puisque
finalement les engagements ne sont
jamais tenues